hey everyone so it's been a few months
since I got my iPhone 15 and I thought I
would do a little updated what's on my
iPhone I changed some things around from
my previous phone because normally when
I get a new iPhone I completely start
from scratch which is kind of annoying
because I have to redownload all of the
apps but I love it because it's a fresh
start on my phone well what I don't like
is I do end up losing all of my messages
but it just feels like a fresh start
every year so let me show you guys what
I have on my phone and how I have it
laid out I don't like a lot of pages I
don't like having more than two pages so
as you'll see here I have one page two
page and I have some folders for some
things like my crypto my house and then
I have shopping production travel and
healthc care and fitness which there's
really actually not that many things in
there but that's fine the number one
thing that you will see though is I do
have my eight sleep widget up here so
huge thank you to eight sleep for
sponsoring a portion of this video
before we get into the rest of the apps
I want to just tell you what it's been
like over the past year of using eight
sleep if you don't know what eight sleep
is it is basically a game Cher when it
comes to getting the best sleep ever
like when I say that this thing has
changed my life no joke it is so
incredible so eight sleep has a mattress
and a pod cover that is temperature
controlled so it'll either heat up or
cool down according to how you like to
sleep and it has made such a huge
difference for me I like to fall asleep
with a little bit colder of a
temperature so as you'll see here my pod
is currently off but I can click in
through the widgets and right now it's
warming it because it's actually
currently at -3 it's a little bit colder
in my house at this point so for me I
like to follow sleep at about a --2 so
this right now is currently at a -2 for
bedtime so I can have this set for all
nights since that is my current
preference and with autopilot it
automatically will adjust to make sure
that I'm at my ideal temperature that I
like my favorite part though is I hate
having an alarm wake me up so I can have
this do a gentle vibration on my half of
the bed and it'll also warm up to a
warmer temperature so it's like a
gradual very very peaceful way to wake
up I've also loved having both sides of
the bed be separate so if your partner
likes to have a colder temperature or a
warmer temperature your bedsides can be
separate and each one of you can sleep
at the ideal temperature the other added
bonus is this has sleep tracking which
I'm so obsessed with this shows your
your sleep Fitness score I had an
incredible sleep there 100% uh 93%
routine and I slept for 8 hours and 32
minutes and I love the detail that this
goes into with your different sleep
stages also your Health metrics your
heart rate HRV your breath rate your
routine your schedule consistency your
sleep latency the time you went to sleep
and it's just so fun to be able to
compare this night after night like I
think I had to fly out this day so you
can see I woke up at 5:30 and then the
next day there's no data because I was
gone and sad because I missed my eight
sleep since having this for the past
year I honestly cannot say enough great
things about it and I know I'm not the
only one I have so many other friends
who also have this and I love being able
to chat with with them about their sleep
scores and how much this has improved
their sleep as well if you guys want to
get more information I will put a link
in the description and let me know if
you have one or if you were looking to
get one I'd love to hear from you so
this is my second home screen but let's
go back and let's go through all of the
apps that I currently have and my
organizational thought process for
whatever reason I like having the
settings right here because I do find
myself going into there quite often so
being able to have that just right up at
the top left that I can quickly just hit
I know where it is it's easy to get to
also the clock I'm always setting alarms
I know I could probably just say hey and
she would set it for me but I do like
having this here also the App Store I'm
always looking for apps downloading
things updating things so I like having
that easily accessible in my first row
my calendar is easily accessible we've
also got Apple Maps and Google Maps
we've got the Tesla app the notes app
which is just by far the most Superior
app in the world we have this app that
was formerly known as Twitter which I
still think is Twitter
so don't get me started TI Tok threads
Instagram and Facebook I like that I
have them all right here kind of close
together but I did kind of want to have
all these three apps matching because
they were all black and they just looked
nice together so that I put Instagram
here there's like a weird thought
process behind all of this I don't know
we've got Snapchat YouTube studio and
the YouTube app then we have my crypto
folder I know I I don't want to hear it
like this is my phone let me let me have
what I want on my phone okay we've got
coinbase helium coinbase pro the rainbow
wallet venmo which is not actually
crypto but it's I basically just using
this as my finance folder metamask
public Phantom wallet trust wallet
Google Authenticator I don't know why
you're in there but that's fine whatever
do what you want Kraken Pro blockfi you
went bankrupt you shouldn't even be
there but whatever po app and AMX you're
also not crypto but it's fine we've got
Discord Spotify Telegram and we have my
home folder so we've got Google home
this is for my garage we've got nest and
of course my eight sleep protect power
viiew Lutron Bravo G Sun that is a home
sprinkler system I don't even think it's
actually connected to be honest with you
which is probably why all my plants are
dying I should look into that ey robot
that's for my vacuum Nano Leaf Trager
that's my grill control center that's to
control the lights in my gaming room uh
ring doorbell washos that's a um Car
Wash app eax home that's also my Robot
vacuum SL mop and of course Apple home
we've got goino pets which is my salana
crypto pet I don't want to hear it I
don't want to hear it okay I'm still I'm
still in it all right whatever I've been
playing this goo pets game for the past
over a year maybe a year and a half I'm
obsessed leave me alone uh we've got
WhatsApp we've got the aura ring and
then down here in the tray I have my
messages I've got the Gmail app Safari
and my camera I love being able to have
the camera easily accessible and you
might be wondering what do I have my
action button set to hold on you're
never going to believe
it it silences my phone I know um so
cool so Innovative next up we have
shopping so I've got postmate store Dash
yummy instacart Blue Bottle Home Depot
zaposlite lights here Luma Fusion which
is a video editor which is basically the
closest thing to Final Cut on the iPhone
that I could find and I'm so obsessed
with it Oceanic this is for the Apple
Watch app to go diving and also to the
oceanic dive housing so that connects to
that uh the GoPro app for controlling my
GoPro the DJI mimo for controlling some
of my DJI devices uh metav View for the
meta rayb bands collab which I'm
obsessed they did such a great job with
us like say what you want about meta but
man the ray bands meta collab is A+ 100%
love it uh captions that's how I add
captions to my videos sometimes um I
don't do it all the time but I do love
this app it's super easy to use Imaging
Edge mobile that's for connecting my
Sony cameras to my phone hover X1 I may
or may not have already posted this
video but if not it's coming out soon it
is this uh drone that basically takes
off from your palm and I also obsessed
with that um I'm obsessed with a lot of
things and can't wait to show you that
video cuz it's super fun remote control
that controls a teleprompter app that I
have I've got the Google app we've got
the Google Docs we have WebEx meet and
the LG soundbar app next we have travel
we've got Delta Uber Spirit American and
surf line um I don't surf but I you know
just sometimes want to see how the waves
are health and fitness we have flow it's
a a period
tracker Apollo is a little wearable
device that sends sound vibrations
through your body to reduce stress I'm
still testing it out so stay tuned for
that um My Fitness Pal sometimes I like
to track my food or look things up and
see how much protein I've had in the day
I need to get back to that but I love my
fitness palic it's just it still has
been one of my favorite apps for food
tracking we've got audible I love
listening to audiobooks like I'm I have
a problem like I listen to them all day
long like I'll be walking around the
house cleaning I'll be driving whatever
that I'm doing that I can be listening
to an Audi book I am so huge audible fan
twitch Disney plus Pandora and then I
have easy access to my Tesla and then
Spotify and of course 1989 Taylor's
version on Deck I actually really love
Spotify I use it more I think than Apple
music which is kind of ironic it is what
it is I've just been using it for so
long that it's just got my playlist it's
got all of my things and I really like
it so yeah my friends that is what is on
my iPhone 15 currently let me know if
there's any apps that you think I should
check out what do you think of my app
layout um I guess I'm going to say like
I don't really like I don't care what
you think about it because this works
for me so um please don't judge or you
can judge me it's fine you can do
whatever you want and if you're
wondering why I don't have a third page
honestly for the longest time I only had
one page and I even had a folder with
all of these other things but finally I
was like okay I like using widgets and I
like having a few other apps that I use
a lot just readily accessible but most
of the time I just swipe down and I
search for whatever app I want so it
really doesn't matter where it is on my
phone but this is my setup so that my
friends I will see you guys in my next
video if you want to see some more
videos I've got some here on the end
screen and if you haven't already be
sure to like comment and subscribe hit
the Bell to be notified when I post new
videos and I'll see you the next one bye